hallo mein name ist luca meine lieben
frau
hallo mein name ist luke habe meine
lieben freunde ich sitze ich jetzt zwar
ganz normal in meinem aufnahme zimmer
allerdings befindet sich haben hinter
der kamera hallo die hat auch mikro
richtig zeigt mal vor die kamera der
mikro
die hatten ja auf jeden fall einige
videos vorbereitet die entweder von mir
in den letzten jahren hochgeladen wurden
oder generell auf youtube hochgeladen
wurden und ich muss anhand der ersten
sekunden des videos erraten von wann
dieses video ist richtig von welchem
jahr in welchem jahr und damit fangen
wir auch direkt an weil sie nicht also
ich komme nicht nach durchgemacht habe
ich komme dann noch gar nicht mehr klar
[Musik]
du hast du das her
ich habe keine ahnung kannst du das
nicht so anhand einer frisur oder so
sagen wenn die frisur war schon immer
los ist eigentlich meine frisur auch
gerade fast genauso also die sache jetzt
halt ich bin auf jeden fall in meinem
alten zimmer und ich weiß dass ich dort
nur videos aufgenommen habe bevor ich
halt logischerweise umgezogen bin und
ich bin umgezogen
2014 zwar 2013 oder
es war 2013
2013 einfach acht jahre her
seit die bullen altach hat wir noch
entscheiden die dann für dieses casino
lila gepasst
also dieses video kenne ich auf jeden
fall schon gegen die gefühlt seit zehn
jahren oder so
oder weiß ich nicht wie lange das kennst
gefühlt wenn ich damit aufgewachsen ich
komm raus aus dem bauch meiner mutter
und dass das erste video was gesehen
aber ich kann jetzt auch nicht viel
quatsch mal eine eigene videos kann ich
mich halt irgendwie kann ich an ansatz
anhalt soll ich sagen
als klar ich sag
2012/2013 auch
aber es ist immer knapp ich bin mein
traum ist es mein traum ich bin drei
video fried die zu haben hey leute ich
stelle euch heute das brandneue michael
minecraft 11 bevor ich denke das ist
einfach ein 1.1 privilegs aber irgendwie
so ein komischer name
ist mit dem sind sind die sprache
nicht was ich habe eure texte packs
dafür schon geupdatet sind meine
jedenfalls nicht einfach draufklicken
findet ihr hier eine menge eine menge
menge sprachen also ziemlich viel ich
weiß ja schon alle hinzugefügt werden
ich kann jetzt einfach mal deutsch
deutschland auswählen und dann seht ihr
schon ich habe hier alles auf deutsch
ich weiß ja das war früher richtig
tragen da kommt bei minecraft einfach
auf deutsch stellen
habe mich freut von daher kann man sich
halt noch erinnern als wäre es gestern
gewesen ich glaube auch allerhand meiner
stimme sondern bis hin zu urteilen + ich
hatte noch keine face käme also ich hab
ich noch nicht gezeigt dass das 2011
oder 2012 mag ich sagt
2011/12
verdacht auf körperverletzung gegen die
vernehmung der polizei abwarten
entweder das ist so von 2011 oder so
oder es ist von 2020 es gibt nichts
dazwischen für mich gerade weil dieses
mal ging ja erst ab vor ein paar jahren
weswegen ich tendiere mal aber er hat ja
auch keine maske auf ich tendiere zu ich
sage so 2009/10
[Musik]
aber du bist immer auf dem richtigen weg
fasst das hat meine lehrer auch mal
gesagt
ein video war am letzten wochenende in
berlin im schloss ich glaube die szenen
von dem schloss habe ich schon oft genug
gezeigt
die sind doch eigentlich recht cool
es war aber krass hat ein kumpel von mir
zusammen geschnitten wir waren noch
seiner fortbildung in die haben
irgendwie sonnen schloss tag gemietet
und da haben wir alle drin gewohnt und
haben auch da
genügt für
das war das bambados das war auf
ich glaub ich glaube das weiß sogar noch
ziemlich genau das war
[Musik]
2015/2016
aber verarscht mich gerade so wild wenn
nehmen und trank für sandra drehen
würden da wäre so eine kamera versteckt
nein gott freuen ich habe den weltrekord
schuldig dass sie richtig ich bin mein
name ist luca und draußen ist es ganz
sehr stark am regnen
es war auf jeden fall in meiner zweiten
wohnung in köln ich bin 2014 nach köln
gezogen und ich glaube 2016 weil ich in
dieser wohnung deswegen würde ich auch
sagen 2016
haben mich verarscht mich stimmt das
wirklich
ich habe noch kein einziges video
richtig
ich sag
ich sag's 2011
freunde an der nordsee hier das war auf
jeden fall vor corona
sommer 2020 kann es nicht gewesen sein
ich glaube das war sommer 2009 10
2020 war doch schon corona junge leute
herzlich willkommen zum heutigen konnte
ich hatte heute keine lust mich einfach
bei diesem 25 grad die es bei uns hier
waren folgt er schon sehr froh ist
das hat sie ein longboard sie dastehen
ich glaube das video ist auf jeden fall
dann entstand als ich noch bei meinen
eltern gewohnt habe plus auch noch zur
schule gegangen bin deswegen sage ich
entweder 2013 oder 2014
ich würde sagen 2014 richtig
mein name ist herzlich willkommen hier
heute zu einem video mich heute
instagram bilder nach
okay es war auf jeden fall im urlaub ich
weiß natürlich dass video zusammen mit
max aufgenommen hat um mit seppl waren
auch irgend so ein spielplatz haben
instagram bildung nachgestellt deswegen
war es auf jeden fall im sommer macht
keinen sinn weil jedes jahr hat einen
sommer allerdings wird ich einfach mal
tippen auf
2017 16
ich frage mich wie das nichts mehr
[Musik]
egal
was du gewartet hallo ich meine lieben
freunde und herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen folge joplin wird zusammen mit
angespielt und comedy aloha so habt ihr
noch moment los nämlich genau in ein
paar sekunden
[Musik]
einer sekunde jetzt aufgeregt ich habe
das noch nie gespielt das muss es ja
machen weil man
wird mich verarscht
[Musik]
er ist ein ganz normaler blog von früher
kann ich nicht
ich habe mir gerade selbst mobil gemacht
aus glas ist
das ist
2000 brothers ich war in meiner neuen
wohl also meiner jetzigen wohnung schon
das muss 2000
17 ja
das video bisher aufruf hat das was
das hat 8,1 millionen was
was
8,1 millionen aufrufe bei dem blog ja
eigentlich müsste ich mal ein video
machen wo du so videos heraussucht und
ich muss anhand der aufrufe muss sich
also anhand der videos muss die aufrufe
erwarten das könnten wir machen an der
stelle würde das heutige wir jetzt auch
beenden meine freunde wenn es euch
gefallen hat das kann einen daumen hoch
unter dem video abonniert main kanal und
klickt auf die glocke wenn ihr weitere
videos nicht verpassen wollt sollen habe
ich das ganze eventuell auch mal mit
jubel luca errät youtube-videos aufrufe
booms beck erraten dann
geht's dir gut dir auch danke schön das
passt halt noch so nix arbeiten arbeiten
arbeiten
schön
was können die leute hier machen
abonnieren ein anderes video angucken
kennen die leute hier machen
das gefeuert
ok